"The Batman" is the latest take on one of
the most recognizable superheroes of all time.
Even the most offhand line in the film reveals
more about the character than you might think.
Wanna know more?
Keep watching.
"I'm vengeance."
Those two words, spotlighted in the trailer,
had already become something of a viral sensation
on social media before the film was released,
similar to a familiar line from Tim Burton's
take on the Caped Crusader.
"He blew his light out!
Now you wanna get nuts?
C'mon!
Let's get nuts!"
But what's interesting is that if you search…
#imvengeance
…on twitter, many people have embraced it
in a way that pokes fun at Batman's constant
brooding and self-seriousness.
Which largely mirrors what happens in the
film.
Although Batman doesn't say the line in the
presence of any of the film's main characters,
that doesn't stop Catwoman from teasing him
about it.
A few others do as well, treating his declaration
like an embarrassing Rage Against the Machine
lyric he once scribbled in their yearbook.
Selena Kyle teases him at one point, saying:
"Come on, Vengeance."
Obviously, certain elements are intrinsic
in the Batman character.
His parents were murdered, and he has since
spent his days and nights training and planning
to become the ultimate crime deterrent.
A big part of his power is the fear he instills
in Gotham's criminals, so if there's anyone
who could credibly utter a line like "I'm
vengeance" with complete sincerity, it would
be The Batman.
But at the same time, Pattinson's Batman is
just beginning to come to grips with the cause-and-effect
his presence has created in Gotham.
The crime is relentless, the villains are
increasingly more dynamic, and his nightly
efforts don't seem to be making much of a
dent.
Overall, there's a sense of near-mockery throughout
"The Batman" with characters like Riddler,
Penguin, and Carmine Falcone treating their
adversary's sincerity as if it's a shortcoming.
"You've got a lot of cats."
"I have a thing about strays."
It's a line spoken coyly by Selina Kyle in
response to Batman's less than genuine observation.
It also sums up this take on the character.
Nearly every action we see from this Catwoman
is motivated by the welfare or memory of someone
else.
She's relentlessly compassionate toward the
vulnerable, just as you'd take in a stray
cat and give it the love it needs to grow.
However, her biggest motivation is her mission
to save her friend who has gone missing.
But like Batman, she always has the memory
of her murdered mother coloring her actions.
Then of course there's Batman himself, another
stray that Selina often pushes, cheers up,
and looks after.
Take a look at the scene where Selina agrees
to wear special contact lenses that broadcast
a video signal to work at the 44 Below club
hidden within Penguin's Iceberg Lounge.
Clearly, she hates being an informant for
Batman.
But she's willing to risk her life to help
out the Bat, and hopefully, get some information
on the missing girl's whereabouts.
In some ways, this take on Catwoman might
be the most purely "good' one fans have seen
in a film.
Sure, she technically retains the skills of
a cat burglar, but she uses them to get back
stolen passports rather than steal family
jewels.
Arguably, she's every bit the "hero" that
Batman is, and unless you're willing to bring
up Halle Berry's Catwoman, Zoe Kravitz's take
on the character is the kindest Catwoman we've seen.
The line is sure to get a giggle from viewers,
and isn't that what the Riddler is all about?
"It's too delicious.
I even gave you a tip-off."
And keep in mind, moviegoers haven't seen
a cinematic take on this character since Jim
Carrey in 1995's "Batman Forever."
More than anyone else in Batman's rogues'
gallery, the man typically known as Edward
Nygma seems made for these times.
The modern world is filled with mind games,
fake news, anonymous troublemakers, and other
touchstones the Riddler once manipulated with
a pen and piece of paper.
This is the perfect opportunity to update
the character into something more threatening
and less cartoonish, and "The Batman" leans
into that.
"Say hello to my followers; we're live!" he
says at one point, kicking off a live stream
with the intention of holding the District
Attorney accountable for his perceived shortcomings.
"They're here to watch our little trial."
The Riddler's creepy new mask, off-kilter
glasses, and affection for duct tape result
in a threatening new look that no green leotard
could approach.
His grainy hostage videos and mocking riddles
work perfectly alongside the user comments
in the corners of the frame.
Riddler uses the tools of social media to
create a formidable army that mimics him in
appearance and technique.
While the Christopher Nolan movies and the
Snyderverse both used modern tech to depict
threats to Batman, neither of them thought
to do so via the Riddler.
Now, the character has been reimagined as
a Jigsaw-like manipulator for the 21st century.
"I want to play a game."
The potential for further development of this
incarnation of Batman's foe, and his "followers,"
seems rife with potential.
This line comes at a key point in the film,
as Bruce Wayne continues to cling to any loose
string he can find of his core principles.
He struggles as Gotham remains a city under
siege, and a rising pile of bodies around
him serves as nagging indications he may be
fighting a losing battle.
Carmine Falcone, one of the most despicable
puppeteers in Gotham, solicits the line when
he approaches Wayne and tries to bond with
him.
"Your father saved my life," says the gangster,
explaining that Thomas Wayne once tended to
him.
"You think that doesn't mean something?"
Dismissing the moment as inconsequential,
Bruce Wayne tells Falcone his father did it
out of obligation, not friendship.
"That means he took the Hippocratic Oath,"
he says.
What you're witnessing here is the final moments
of Bruce Wayne's naive view of the way the
world works.
In almost every incarnation of Batman, Thomas
and Martha Wayne are hugely powerful, hugely
beloved characters senselessly gunned down.
They are perfect martyrs for Batman to avenge.
But not in "The Batman."
Instead, further revelations are to come about
how Thomas and Martha rose to power, silenced
their critics, and hid their secrets.
In short, Thomas was far from a noble doctor
who treated everyone equally.
As the line becomes blurred between Carmine
Falcone and Thomas Wayne, it eats away at
the very foundation of the Batman mission.
Could it be that Thomas Wayne wouldn't simply
help someone out of professionalism and duty?
Could it be that Falcone was ... a friend?
For all his fancy talk and Machiavellian mind
games, Falcone is just another homicidal thug.
This becomes evident in the final scenes involving
the character.
When he is confronted by Selina, their struggle
leads to him nearly strangling her.
Both Bruce Wayne and Selina Kyle have significant
backstories involving dead parents and their
involvement with the movie's lead gangster.
Falcone, however, is a relatively recent creation
in the Batman universe.
He made his debut in a 1987 comic.
And although his criminal activity has often
been a driving force behind Gotham's sorry
state, this is perhaps the most influential
we've ever seen the character.
In essence, without Falcone, there likely
wouldn't be a Batman or a Catwoman.
But during a far more primal moment, Falcone
tells Catwoman "You made me do this.
Just like your mother."
as he tries to choke her to death.
This confession that he did, in fact, kill
Maria Kyle should bring closure for Selena
on some level.
Though she's not able to appreciate it until
Falcone is finally knocked off her and arrested.
Where does Selena go from here?
Like several of the other main characters
in "The Batman," she is essentially a grown
orphan, grappling with demons and ghosts she
cannot ignore.
The last time we see Selena, her storyline
is resolved, she has no one left to be with,
and she's heading off on her motorcycle to
start a new life.
Now, it seems, she's the stray.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about "The Batman"
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.